In Danielle's house, ever since she was a girl, when holiday dinners come, they serve this meal that might look familiar to you. The main course on a big platter, drumsticks, white breast meat, stuffing and gravy, cranberry relish on the side. And in Danielle's family, they have a name for this meal that she told me on the phone. The name for this meal is--
在丹妮尔家里，从她小时候起，每逢节日晚餐，他们都会上一道你可能很熟悉的菜。主菜装在一个大盘子里，有鸡腿、白鸡胸肉、填料和肉汁，旁边是蔓越莓酱。在丹妮尔的家族里，他们给这顿饭起了一个名字，她在电话里告诉了我。这顿饭的名字叫——
Fish.
鱼。
Got that?
听到了吗？
Fish.
鱼。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. A special program today on the wonders of fish. Actually, we can say the word here. And the word is poultry. And as you know, each week on our program we choose some theme, invite a variety of writers and performers to tackle that theme. And this week, as we stand now, in that magical five weeks of the year, that magical five weeks between the turkey served at Thanksgiving and the turkey served at Christmas, a period when Americans consume nearly 1/4 of all the turkey consumed in this country every year. 67 million turkeys are eaten during this period. And every year during this important time, This American Life brings you yet another program about poultry. That's right, stories about turkeys, chickens, ducks, fowl of all kind, and their mysterious hold over us.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。今天是一个关于鱼之奇迹的特别节目。其实，我们在这里可以说那个词。那个词是家禽。如你所知，我们每周都会在节目中选定一个主题，邀请各种作家和表演者来探讨这个主题。而本周，当我们正处于一年中那神奇的五周时，也就是感恩节供应的火鸡和圣诞节供应的火鸡之间的那神奇的五周，在这期间，美国人消耗了全国每年近1/4的火鸡。这段时间共食用了6700万只火鸡。每年的这个重要时刻，《美国生活》都会为你带来另一期关于家禽的节目。没错，就是关于火鸡、鸡、鸭，以及各种禽类，还有它们对我们那种神秘的吸引力的故事。
I'm Ira Glass. Coming up in this hour, Act One, Duki. The story of a typical American family, imaginary poultry, and a hand puppet. Act Two, Still Life with Chicken, what happens when a chicken crosses that thin, yellow line that divides the animals that we eat, on the one hand, and the animals that we keep as pets on the other. Act Three, How to do the Funky Chicken, the true story of a multinational chicken company powerful enough to turn a white man into a black man, and the man they chose to do this to, well, an old-time Kentucky colonel who happened to be their own spokesman. Act Four, Chicken Diva, yet another testimony to the power that chickens have over our hearts and minds, my friend, an opera about Chicken Little, done with dressed-up Styrofoam balls, sung in Italian, and-- no kidding-- able to make grown men cry. Stick around and hear it for yourself.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。在这一小时里，第一幕，《杜基》。这是一个典型美国家庭、想象中的家禽和手偶的故事。第二幕，《鸡之静物》，当一只鸡越过了那条划分我们食用的动物和我们当作宠物的动物的细黄线时，会发生什么。第三幕，《如何跳小鸡舞》，这是一个关于跨国养鸡公司的真实故事，它强大到足以把一个白人变成黑人，而他们选中的那个男人，嗯，是一位恰好是他们代言人的肯塔基州老上校。第四幕，《小鸡歌后》，这是又一个证明鸡对我们的心灵有着强大影响力的见证，我的朋友，这是一个关于《四眼天鸡》的歌剧，由装扮好的泡沫球表演，用意大利语演唱，而且——说真的——能让成年男人落泪。留下来，亲自听听吧。
Act One, Duki. So in Danielle's family, the power of poultry is so great in their lives that when they serve chicken or turkey, they call it--
第一幕，《杜基》。在丹妮尔的家里，家禽在他们的生活中有着如此巨大的影响力，以至于当他们供应鸡肉或火鸡时，他们称它为——
Fish.
鱼。
That's right. And they call it this for a reason. And the reason has to do with a stuffed hand puppet called Duki. Now, Danielle is a woman over 30 years old. Her sister Ashley is two years younger. Duki has been in the family since they were children.
没错。他们这样称呼是有原因的。而这个原因与一个名叫杜基的填充手偶有关。丹妮尔今年30多岁了，她的妹妹阿什利比她小两岁。杜基从她们小时候起就在家里了。
Well, he was a Christmas present when Ashley was about eight and I was about 10. And when he first arrived, he was really fluffy. And he was this beautiful, fluffy, white duck. And he had a cape on and black, kind of, villain slash hero goggles. He lost the outfit pretty quickly and he went naked. And then he became Ashley's vehicle for torturing me.
嗯，那是阿什利大约八岁、我十岁时收到的圣诞礼物。他刚到家时毛茸茸的，是一只漂亮、蓬松的白鸭子。他披着一件斗篷，戴着黑色的、那种反派兼英雄的护目镜。他很快就弄丢了这套行头，变得光秃秃的了。然后他成了阿什利折磨我的工具。
Now, it's not unusual for older siblings to dominate younger ones. And as children, Danielle dominated Ashley. Ashley looked up to Danielle, fought to get her attention and her approval, and Danielle always, always got her way, except when Duki was around. Basically, Ashley would channel-- I mean, the word's kind of an anachronism in this context-- but she would channel Duki. She would become Duki's voice. She would speak as Duki. And Duki was sarcastic. Duki was selfish and bossy. Duki would insult Danielle. Duki would tease Danielle. Duki would give her painful nose squeaks.
年长的兄弟姐妹支配年幼的兄弟姐妹并不罕见。小时候，丹妮尔总是支配阿什利。阿什利仰视丹妮尔，努力争取她的注意和认可，而丹妮尔总是随心所欲，除非杜基在场。基本上，阿什利会引导——我的意思是，在这个语境下这个词有点过时——但她会引导杜基。她会成为杜基的声音。她会以杜基的身份说话。杜基很刻薄，杜基很自私且爱指手画脚。杜基会侮辱丹妮尔，会取笑丹妮尔，还会用力捏丹妮尔的鼻子。
Whenever Ashley brought Duki into the equation, he was completely the dominant force. I was just putty in Duki's hands.
每当阿什利把杜基带入这个局面，他就是完全的统治力量。在杜基面前，我简直就像橡皮泥一样任人摆布。
Let me ask you to compare his personality with Ashley's personality.
请你比较一下他的个性和阿什利的个性。
Ashley's very kind of considerate and-- she's very considerate and kind and thoughtful, and very, very sensitive to other people, very, very concerned about if other people are happy, and if someone or someone else doesn't feel good. And Duki just has this total, you know, what's-for-lunch attitude. Like, what's in it for me? In your face, totally out for himself, simultaneously a braggart and a total wimp.
阿什利非常体贴，她很体贴、善良、周到，对别人非常非常敏感，非常非常关心别人是否快乐，或者是否有人感到不舒服。而杜基完全就是一种“午饭吃什么”的态度。比如，我能得到什么好处？他很傲慢，完全只为自己着想，同时又是个吹牛大王和胆小鬼。
He's boastful and vain.
他很爱吹嘘，也很虚荣。
He's just this indomitable spirit.
他就是那种不屈不挠的精神。
All right, I've been at Danielle's apartment sometimes, and I've witnessed the following scene. Picture please. Danielle has not spoken with her sister in weeks. She picks up the phone, calls Ashley in Michigan. Ashley answers. Danielle asks immediately, can you put Duki on? And then Ashley essentially becomes Duki, puts Duki on the phone. Danielle talks to Duki for 15, 20 minutes, and then they both hang up. That's the whole conversation. And they both feel satisfied. Danielle is an editor at a big New York magazine.
好了，我有时在丹妮尔的公寓里，目睹过这样的场景。请想象一下。丹妮尔已经几周没和她妹妹说话了。她拿起电话，打给在密歇根州的阿什利。阿什利接听了。丹妮尔立即问道，能让杜基接电话吗？然后阿什利基本上变成了杜基，让杜基接电话。丹妮尔和杜基聊了15、20分钟，然后他们都挂断了。这就是整个谈话。他们都感到很满足。丹妮尔是一家大型纽约杂志的编辑。
I adore Duki. I really love Duki. And sometimes I think, like, if he disappeared it would really feel like someone died. I mean, I look at him and he looks really kind of old and ratty. And it really makes me sad. It kind of really-- I feel like-- I mean, it sounds crazy. I mean, it really makes me sad to think about a world without Duki, and it would be a big, empty hole in the world. He kind of takes up as much room in my heart as a lot of people, individually. And if something happened to him, you know, if he were like lost in an airport, or kind of run over by a car, I would be-- I mean, it would really be heart-breaking.
我崇拜杜基。我真的非常爱杜基。有时我觉得，如果他消失了，真的会感觉像有人去世了一样。我的意思是，我看着他，他看起来真的很老旧、破烂。这让我真的很伤心。它真的让我——我的意思是，这听起来很疯狂。想到一个没有杜基的世界，我真的感到很难过，那会是世界上一个巨大的、空虚的洞。他在我心中的分量和很多人差不多。如果他出了什么事，你知道，如果他在机场走丢了，或者被车撞了，我会——我的意思是，那真的会令人心碎。
So I hope it's becoming clear why, if you eat dinner in the home of Danielle's family, if they're serving some kind of poultry-- you know, chicken or turkey-- if you ask anybody in the family what's for dinner, they'll tell you--
所以我希望这足以解释为什么如果你在丹妮尔家里吃晚饭，如果他们供应某种家禽——比如鸡肉或火鸡——如果你问家里的任何人晚饭吃什么，他们会告诉你——
Fish.
鱼。
Right. And the rationale for that is what?
对。那么理由是什么呢？
It freaks Duki out.
这会让杜基抓狂。
It freaks him out, though-- you don't like him to know that perhaps some birds are, in fact, eaten?
这让他抓狂，但——你不希望让他知道事实上有些鸟确实被吃掉吗？
I think he knows. I think he's in denial about it. He's in denial about most things. He's in denial about the fact that he's totally weak, and tiny, and dirty. He thinks he's really good-looking and strong and that he's really smart and has a lot of friends. He's in denial about the fact that he's actually stuffed, which he is. Sometimes I tell him that. I say, Duki, give me a break. You're just stuffed. And he's like, no way.
我想他知道。我想他在否认这一点。他对大多数事情都在否认。他否认自己完全虚弱、渺小且肮脏的事实。他认为自己非常帅气、强壮，认为自己很聪明且有很多朋友。他否认自己其实是个填充玩具的事实，而他确实是。有时我会告诉他。我说，杜基，算了吧。你只是个填充玩具。他会说，才不是呢。
Now, I thought I would try to book Duki to come on the radio for this program. So I contacted Danielle's sister Ashley and asked her, you know, could Duki come on the air. I received an answer back, not by phone but by electronic mail, that for Duki to appear I'd have to first go through someone named Yona Lu, who I could reach through Danielle and Ashley's mother. And when I talked to Danielle, I asked her about this.
我想我应该试着预约杜基来参加这个节目。所以我联系了丹妮尔的妹妹阿什利，问她，杜基能不能上节目。我收到了一封回复，不是通过电话，而是通过电子邮件，说要让杜基出场，我必须先通过一个名叫尤娜·卢的人，我可以通过丹妮尔和阿什利的母亲联系到她。当我与丹妮尔交谈时，我问了她这件事。
I've been informed that the only way that I can reach him is by calling your mom and speaking to Yona Lu. Do I have that name right?
我被告知联系他的唯一方法是打给你妈妈，找尤娜·卢说话。那个名字我没记错吧？
Yona Lu, yeah. I think that she's acting as his agent.
尤娜·卢，是的。我想她在担任他的经纪人。
Yona Lu is?
尤娜·卢是吗？
She's a hedgehog.
她是一只刺猬。
Anything special that I should say to Yona Lu to make this happen?
有什么特别的话是我该对尤娜·卢说的，好让她促成这件事吗？
I mean, I don't know. She drives a pretty hard bargain.
我的意思是，我不知道。她可是个很难讨价还价的家伙。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Hey, Mrs. Mattoon?
嘿，马通太太？
Yes?
是的？
It's Ira Glass.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Hi, Ira Glass.
你好，艾拉·格拉斯。
Mrs. Mattoon, here's why I called you. I want to do a little story on the radio about Duki.
马通太太，我打电话给您是因为我想在广播里做一个关于杜基的小故事。
Duki?
杜基？
Duki. And I contacted your daughter Ashley, and she said that for me to book Duki onto my radio show, I was going to first need to contact Yona Lu.
杜基。我联系了您的女儿阿什利，她说如果我想预订杜基上我的广播节目，我需要先联系尤娜·卢。
[LAUGHS] Yeah, you would need to do that.
[笑] 是的，你确实需要那样做。
And that I needed to do that through you. Who is Yona Lu?
而且我需要通过您来联系。尤娜·卢是谁？
Yona Lu is-- she's kind of a-- she's a hedgehog. She's basically taken charge of Duki's financial affairs. I presume this is something to do with money?
尤娜·卢是——她是一种——她是一只刺猬。她基本上负责处理杜基的财务事务。我猜这和钱有关？
Well, I don't know, actually. I mean, we--
嗯，其实我不知道。我的意思是，我们——
That's probably why she said to contact Yona Lu.
那可能就是她让你联系尤娜·卢的原因。
Well, so what do I do now? I'm calling. I was told to contact you if I wanted to get in touch with Yona Lu in order to book Duki. What do I do next?
那么我该怎么办呢？我正在打电话。有人告诉我如果我想联系尤娜·卢以预订杜基，就必须联系您。下一步我该做什么？
Book Duki, OK. You're going to book Duki?
预订杜基，好的。你要预订杜基？
That's the whole idea. I want to book Duki for the show, for an interview.
就是这个想法。我想预订杜基上节目，进行一次采访。
Well, I'll just talk to Yona Lu about it. If she says OK, it's OK.
好吧，我会和尤娜·卢谈谈。如果她说行，那就行。
I mean, will Yona Lu want to discuss terms or something?
我的意思是，尤娜·卢会想要讨论条款之类的吗？
She doesn't talk.
她不说话。
So what's going to happen? All right. Should I call you back?
那么会发生什么呢？好的。我是不是该再给您打电话？
You could call me back, or I'll just go in and check.
你可以再给我打，或者我进去问一下。
You'll just go in and check? Should I wait?
你进去问一下？我需要等吗？
Yeah.
是的。
All right, I'll wait.
好的，我会等的。
Ira?
艾拉？
Yeah.
在。
This is just radio? Not TV?
这只是广播节目吗？不是电视？
It's just radio.
只是广播。
And nobody's going to get to be on TV?
没人能上电视吗？
No. No one's going to be on TV. No, it's strictly radio.
不。没人会上电视。不，严格来说只是广播。
OK. Yona doesn't care what happens then.
好的。那尤娜就不在乎会发生什么了。
What if it were TV?
如果是电视节目会怎样？
I think she'd want to be on, too. I mean, radio doesn't do much for her, she doesn't talk.
我想她也会想上电视。我的意思是，广播对她来说没什么意义，她又不说话。
All right. As you might imagine, not everybody in the family takes all this so lightly. Danielle's father was never too keen on this.
好的。如你所想，并非家里每个人都对这一切轻描淡写。丹妮尔的父亲从没太喜欢这件事。
He was quite actually bothered by the whole-- he thought we maybe had a problem in the family.
他其实对整件事感到非常困扰——他认为我们家可能出了什么问题。
Really?
真的吗？
I mean, for a while there, we had two daughters that only communicated through a duck.
我的意思是，有一段时间，我们有两个只通过一只鸭子进行沟通的女儿。
You know, that period that you're describing, when do you mean?
你知道，你所描述的那段时期，你是指什么时候？
I would say they maybe were 10 and 12, or nine and 11.
我想她们大概10岁和12岁，或者9岁和11岁。
And they would only communicate through the duck?
她们真的只通过那只鸭子交流？
Well, Danielle didn't pay a whole lot of attention to Ashley but she paid quite a lot of attention to the duck. So if Ashley wanted to get Danielle's attention, all she had to do was rev up the duck.
嗯，丹妮尔不太关注阿什利，但她非常关注那只鸭子。所以如果阿什利想引起丹妮尔的注意，她只需要让鸭子动起来就行了。
How long did this last?
这种情况持续了多久？
Um, I can't remember. She'd also make Danielle laugh that way. Danielle thought Duki was very funny, but I can't remember her thinking Ashley was funny.
嗯，我不记得了。她也会用那种方式让丹妮尔大笑。丹妮尔认为杜基很有趣，但我记不得她觉得阿什利有趣。
In terms of the relationship between my sister and me-- I don't know why. I mean, this is probably completely really sick-- but I have so much genuine affection and love for Duki that it's very easy, and it's very easy to demonstrate those feelings, in a way that it's not as easy to kind of demonstrate those feelings toward my sister, just because we never kind of got in the habit of it.
就我和我妹妹之间的关系而言——我不知道为什么。我的意思是，这可能真的很不健康——但我对杜基有着如此真诚的感情和爱，以至于这很容易，而且很容易表现出来，不像对我妹妹表现出那种感情那样容易，仅仅是因为我们从没养成那种习惯。
What percentage of your relationship with your sister is based on your relationship with Duki?
你和你妹妹的关系中有多少百分比是建立在你和杜基的关系之上的？
Well, the really fun part of it is based on my relationship with Duki. But I think as we've gotten older and older, we've gotten more and more self-conscious about the Duki factor in our relationship. But I think kind of a big chunk. I mean, it definitely kind of gives me this vision into her brain that I wouldn't have otherwise.
嗯，其中非常有趣的部分是建立在我与杜基的关系上的。但我认为随着我们越来越大，我们对关系中的杜基因素变得越来越自觉。但我认为还是占了很大一部分。我的意思是，它确实让我能够洞察她的思想，否则我是做不到的。
Well, I did finally snag an interview with Duki by calling Ashley.
好吧，我最终通过给阿什利打电话，争取到了对杜基的采访。
Is Duki still up for this?
杜基还想参加吗？
Yeah, he just got back from a party, though.
可以，不过他刚从派对回来。
He just got back from a party?
他刚从派对回来？
Yeah. He was at a happy hour thing with a lot of college students. He's not in college, but he's in a band. So a lot of his friends go to this happy hour on Friday night.
是的。他和一群大学生在欢乐时光聚会。他不在上大学，但他组了个乐队。所以他有很多朋友周五晚上去参加这个欢乐时光。
All right. Well, could you get him?
好吧。那么，你能让他过来吗？
Uh, sure. He's upstairs. Just a sec. Here he is.
呃，当然。他在楼上。等一下。他来了。
Hey, Duki?
嘿，杜基？
Yeah? Hey Ira, how you doing?
什么事？嘿，艾拉，你好吗？
I'm just fine.
我很好。
Long time no see.
好久不见。
Long time no see back at you. And welcome to our little radio program.
好久不见。欢迎来到我们的小广播节目。
So what's going on here? You've got a whole bunch of celebrities on tonight?
那么这里是怎么回事？你今晚请了很多大牌明星吗？
Well, we actually have a number of different people--
嗯，我们其实邀请了许多不同的人——
What abouts, like, Tom Cruise?
像汤姆·克鲁斯那样的？
They're just like Tom Cruise. Now Duki, I was talking to Danielle for our radio program and had her come on and talk about you a little bit. And one of the things that she said was that when she was younger, in order to discipline her if she was doing something that you didn't like, you could pretty much control her with something called nose squeaks.
他们就像汤姆·克鲁斯一样。杜基，我之前在广播节目中采访了丹妮尔，让她谈论了一下你。她说的一件事是，当她还小的时候，如果你做了你不喜欢的事，为了管教她，你基本上可以用所谓的“鼻子吱吱声”来控制她。
Yeah, because she has this kind of-- it's a prominent nose. You know what I mean? It kind of sticks out and you just want to squeak it. You know, over Thanksgiving, we're watching the Muppet Show, and Miss Piggy was on, and she reminded me a lot of Neelie.
对，因为她有那种——鼻子很突出。你明白我的意思吗？它会凸出来，你就是想去捏它。感恩节的时候，我们在看《布偶秀》，猪小姐也在场，她让我想起了妮莉。
Of Danielle?
丹妮尔？
Mm-hmm. And Kermit told Miss Piggy to move the pork. And so I was telling Neelie to move the pork all week.
嗯。科米蛙叫猪小姐去搬猪肉。所以我整个星期都在叫妮莉去搬猪肉。
And would she move?
她会搬吗？
Yes, she would. She would.
是的，她会。她会搬的。
Now, if Ashley would tell her-- if Ashley would sit down on the couch and say to Danielle, move the pork, what would the effect of that be?
那么，如果阿什利叫她——如果阿什利坐在沙发上对丹妮尔说，去搬猪肉，那会有什么效果？
Kind of-- you know Neelie. You know how she looks at you when she doesn't approve of something you say or do? She gets this kind of ice cold stare and she gives you this sidelong glance that makes you feel like you're about the size of a pea? That's what she does.
那种——你了解妮莉。你知道当她不赞同你说的话或做的事时，她怎么看你吗？她会露出那种冰冷的眼神，斜视着你，让你觉得自己像豆子那么大？她就是那样做的。
Is there anything about the life of a duck that perhaps you could tell our radio audience that we might not know? You know, I'm sure that you know much more about it than we do.
关于鸭子的生活，有什么是你觉得可以告诉我们的广播听众，而我们可能不知道的吗？你知道，我相信你肯定比我们了解得多。
No, not really. I'm kind of an unusual duck. I'm not really in touch with the whole duck scene.
不，其实没什么。我是个不寻常的鸭子。我并不真正了解整个鸭子世界。
You're not in touch with the whole scene.
你不了解整个世界。
When I had time, I used to migrate once in a while, because I had some friends who are ducks. And I try to keep in touch with them. But lately I've just started spending more time with people and doing my own thing. And I just don't have time to do those kinds of duck things anymore. I just wanted more out of my life than that.
当我有时间的时候，我偶尔会迁徙，因为我有一些鸭子朋友。我也试着和他们保持联系。但最近我开始花更多时间与人相处，做我自己的事情。我只是没有时间再做那些鸭子做的事情了。我想要的生活不仅仅是那样。
Duki, a stuffed hand puppet, now lives in New York City.
杜基，一个填充手偶，现在居住在纽约市。
[MUSIC -- "SATURDAY NIGHT FISH FRY" BY LOUIS JORDAN]
[音乐——路易斯·乔丹的《周六夜鱼排》]
Act Two, Still Life with Chicken. It was an accident that Jonathan ended up living with a chicken. He was not living the kind of lifestyle that one usually associates with chicken.
第二幕，《鸡之静物》。乔纳森和一只鸡住在一起纯属意外。他当时过的生活方式通常与鸡没什么关联。
This was during the period when I considered myself to be a performance artist of sorts. A naked performance artist, to be specific.
那是在我自认为是某种行为艺术家的时候。具体来说，是一个裸体行为艺术家。
These days, Jonathan Gold is a food writer. This all happened 15 years ago in southern California. He was putting together a performance. He had a PA system, which could put out the requisite amount of annoying feedback sound at high decibels. He had the two full bottles of Glade American Beauty air freshener, which he would spray in their entirety in the performance space. And he had a live chicken which he bought the day before the performance from one of those Chinese poultry markets in Los Angeles. And it comes the day of the show. An audience gathers in a darkened warehouse in West LA.
如今，乔纳森·戈德是一位美食作家。这一切发生在15年前的南加州。当时他正在筹备一场演出。他有一套扩音系统，可以发出所需分贝的高频恼人的反馈声。他有两整瓶“佳洁士美国之美”空气清新剂，他会在演出空间里全部喷完。他还有一只活鸡，是他演出前一天从洛杉矶的一家华人禽肉市场买的。演出当天到了。观众聚集在西洛杉矶一个漆黑的仓库里。
I don't know if you've been to a lot of performance art, but this was sort of really typical of the stuff that was going on in the period. And I showed up and I was naked and I was carrying a machete and I was blindfolded. And I stood in the middle of this pile of supermarket chickens. You know, the broilers that you buy. And the chicken that I had bought was tethered to a three-foot rope around me. And I hacked up and down blindly with the machete.
我不知道你有没有看过很多行为艺术，但这在当时非常典型。我上场时全身赤裸，带着一把砍刀，蒙着眼睛。我站在一堆超市买的鸡中间。你知道，就是你买的那种肉鸡。我买的那只鸡被拴在周围的一根三英尺长的绳子上。我盲目地用砍刀乱砍。
Toward the chicken or just in general?
是朝着鸡砍，还是随便砍？
Well, I was blindfolded, so I didn't know if it was towards the chicken or not. And I had fully intended that, in fact, I would kill the chicken in the midst of this performance. But chickens aren't that stupid. And this chicken wanted no part of the machete. It stayed at the end of its rope the entire time apparently. And after 10 minutes, when I was completely exhausted, I fell to a heap. And everybody left and the performance was over.
嗯，我蒙着眼睛，所以不知道是不是朝着鸡砍。我当时确实打算在演出中把鸡杀了。但鸡并不那么笨。这只鸡一点也不想碰那把砍刀。它似乎一直待在绳子的另一端。10分钟后，当我筋疲力尽时，我瘫倒在一堆。大家都走了，演出结束了。
I don't know if you've stuck around after an art performance, but the few minutes after an art performance are some of the most depressing in the world.
我不知道你在艺术表演后有没有留下来，但艺术表演后的那几分钟是世界上最令人沮丧的时刻之一。
How so?
怎么说？
You've done your wad. You've done your sort of bit for art, which has either worked or it hasn't. But you're sitting there, you're covered with chicken effluvium, in my case. It stinks to high hell. Everybody's gone and you've got to clean up. And you're naked. It's really not a pretty picture.
你已经竭尽全力了。你已经完成了你为艺术所做的部分，要么成功了，要么失败了。但你坐在那里，浑身沾满了鸡的排泄物——以我为例。臭气熏天。大家都走了，你必须清理干净。而且你还是赤身裸体。这景象实在不太好看。
So Jonathan cleaned up, and when he was done he had a chicken. And he didn't feel like he could kill the chicken. Destiny had brought them together. He felt like he could not turn his back. He says it was the same as if a kitten shows up on your back door, scratching and lonely and needy. So he took the chicken home. And in doing that, he stumbled across that thin, thin line that separates food items on the one hand from pets on the other, that divides the animals we eat from the animals we love.
于是乔纳森清理干净了，当他做完时，他还有一只鸡。他觉得自己无法杀了这只鸡。命运把他们带到了一起。他觉得他不能背弃它。他说这就像一只小猫出现在你家后门，又抓挠又孤独又需要照顾一样。所以他把鸡带回了家。这样做的时候，他无意中跨过了那条纤细的、划分食物与宠物、将我们食用的动物与我们喜爱的动物分开的线。
So I get home and I have this chicken, and I don't know what to do with it. So I spread out some newspaper on the top of my refrigerator and I put the chicken up there. I get a can of Green Giant brand niblets from under the counter. And I open it and I put it in a little bowl for the chicken. And I give the chicken a little water. And the chicken's on top of my refrigerator.
所以我回到家，有了这只鸡，却不知道该怎么办。于是我在冰箱顶上铺了些报纸，把鸡放在上面。我从柜台下拿出一罐绿巨人牌玉米粒。我打开它，把它装在一个小碗里给鸡吃。我还给鸡弄了点水。这只鸡就待在我的冰箱顶上。
Because you think chickens eat corn. You'd read that or something. And that was the available corn.
因为你觉得鸡吃玉米。你可能读到过之类的。而那是现成的玉米。
That was the available corn. I wish I had thought better of the niblets idea.
那是现成的玉米。我真希望当初能对玉米粒这个想法三思。
Why?
为什么？
Because, in fact, if you're buying three or four cans of niblets a day-- which is what the chicken ate-- and you're existing on almost nothing-- which I was-- then your niblet bill turns out to be like some two-figure percentage of your total income each week. I mean, if you can imagine living on $50 a week, but $10 of it goes for niblets, it's just hard to justify an expense like that.
因为，事实上，如果你每天买三四罐玉米粒——这就是这只鸡吃的量——而你几乎没什么收入——这就是我的情况——那么你的玉米粒账单每周会占你总收入的两位数百分比。我的意思是，如果你能想象每周只靠50美元生活，其中10美元却要买玉米粒，那这种支出就很难证明合理了。
And the chicken stayed there on top of my refrigerator for a long time, months. Six months, I think.
这只鸡就在冰箱顶上待了很长一段时间，好几个月。我想是六个月。
Is this like a one-room apartment?
这就像是一个单间公寓吗？
A two-room apartment. I had a kitchen and a bedroom. So I didn't have to look at the chicken when I was sleeping. Though I did have to look at it when I was cooking.
两间屋的公寓。我有一个厨房和一个卧室。所以我睡觉时不用看着鸡。不过我做饭时必须看着它。
Did you ever cook chicken?
你煮过鸡肉吗？
Of course I cooked chicken.
我当然煮过鸡肉。
Didn't you feel intensely disloyal?
难道你没觉得极其不忠吗？
No, I felt no particular loyalty to this chicken. I don't know if you've ever had chickens, but it's not like-- I mean, you don't pet chickens. Chickens don't really like you to pet them. And you don't hold them. There's really no love that you feel for a chicken in your life, I don't think.
不，我对这只鸡没有什么特别的忠诚感。我不知道你有没有养过鸡，但这不像——我的意思是，你不会去抚摸鸡。鸡真的不喜欢你摸它们。你也不会抱着它们。我不认为生活中你真的会对鸡产生什么爱。
But yet you kept the chicken?
但你还是留下了那只鸡？
I kept the chicken because I couldn't bear to do anything else. And it's not like I could have carried out onto Pico Boulevard and said, be free, little chicken. Be free.
我留下它是为了我无法忍受做别的事。而且我也不可能把它带到皮科大道上说，去吧，小鸡。自由吧。
Did you give the chicken a name?
你给鸡起名字了吗？
I never named the chicken. When I referred to the chicken in public, I always called it the hen.
我从没给鸡起过名字。当我在公共场合提到这只鸡时，我总是叫它“那只母鸡”。
How did you not name it? It was a creature in your house.
你居然没起名字？它是你家里的一个生物。
The chicken always seemed temporary. It never occurred to me that I might have the chicken as long as six months. The chicken always seemed like something that I would have for just a couple days.
这只鸡看起来总是暂时的。我从未想过我会养这只鸡长达六个月。这只鸡看起来总是那种我只会养几天的事物。
And then what did you think was going to happen?
那你觉得会发生什么？
I guess I thought-- A, I thought about the chicken expiring. B, I have to admit that there was a possibility that someday I would actually cook the chicken. I went through a lot of chicken recipes, hundreds and hundreds of chicken recipes.
我想我当时想——第一，我考虑过鸡会死亡。第二，我不得不承认，有一天我确实有可能把这只鸡煮了。我查过很多鸡肉食谱，成百上千种鸡肉食谱。
Thinking maybe this'll be the recipe for my niblet-fed chicken?
心想也许这就是我那只吃玉米粒长大的鸡的食谱？
I'm not sure that a recipe existed that would've lived up to the fact of the chicken, this animal who you have come to know on fairly intimate terms, and who you've raised, and you've put a certain amount of emotion into.
我不确定是否存在一种食谱能配得上这只鸡，这只你已经相当了解、抚养过，并投入了某种情感的动物。
A chicken, if I might say, who has seen you naked.
如果我可以说的话，这只鸡可是见过你赤身裸体的。
The chicken did see me naked, damn it.
这只鸡确实见过我裸体，该死的。
The fact is, we need food to be just food. And as soon as it becomes a living thing, especially if we're city people, you know, we're not used to the conversion of living things into our food, it's hard to handle without thinking it has to be bigger than food, you know, without wanting to make it ritualized or something bigger than food.
事实上，我们需要食物仅仅是食物。一旦它变成活物，尤其是如果我们是城市居民，你知道，我们不习惯将活物转化为我们的食物，如果不觉得它必须大于食物，如果不想要将其仪式化或赋予它超越食物的意义，是很难处理的。
Exactly. Can I tell you a small story?
正是如此。我能讲个小故事吗？
Yeah, of course.
当然可以。
A few weeks ago, I was in this Korean restaurant in Koreatown in Los Angeles. It was this place called The Living Fish Center that I'd always wanted to go because the name of it was so splendid. You know, Living Fish Center. I imagined some sort of vast vivarium where Flipper was jumping through hoops and stuff. And I go in there, and of course it's just like a crummy Korean restaurant. I mean, it's not that clean. And I don't know, there are tanks and stuff, but I didn't know what to order. So I order a fish soup, because it looks like they have a small fish soup specialty on the menu. And it comes and it's just really strong-smelling and not that great.
几周前，我在洛杉矶韩国城的一家韩国餐馆里。那地方叫“活鱼中心”，我一直很想去，因为名字太辉煌了。你知道，“活鱼中心”。我想象着某种巨大的水族馆，海豚在跳圈之类的。我进去了，当然它就像一家蹩脚的韩国餐馆。我的意思是，不是很干净。而且我不知道，有鱼缸之类的，但我不知道点什么。于是我点了鱼汤，因为菜单上似乎有小鱼汤特色菜。端上来的时候味道特别重，没那么好。
And I try squid fried with bean sauce and onions, which wasn't that happening. And I'm about to give up and pay the check and go home with a vast table filled with uneaten stuff. And it suddenly occurs to me what the specialty of the restaurant is. And I wave the waitress over and I tell her that I'd like a prawn. And she is puzzled. She didn't expect me to ask for a prawn. But I repeat my question, and she shrugs and goes and tells the sushi chef.
我试了豆酱炒鱿鱼和洋葱，也不怎么样。我正打算放弃，结账回家，留下一桌没吃的菜。突然我想到这家餐馆的特色是什么了。我叫过服务员，说我想吃一只大虾。她很困惑。她没想到我会要大虾。但我重复了我的问题，她耸耸肩，去告诉了寿司厨师。
And he goes to one side of the restaurant and he climbs on this chair, this ordinary folding chair, and he reaches into this long tank that's running just below the ceiling. And he wiggles his fingers in the water. When he wiggles the fingers, the prawns just become enraged. And they start nipping at his fingers and they start attacking him. And he picks out a couple of the liveliest ones and brings them back to his counter and-- without washing his hands, mind you-- makes a few motions over it. And a couple seconds later, the waitress comes over with the prawns on this huge mound of ice. And what he'd done is he'd taken off the exoskeleton. The head was intact, and that little part of the tail that is always on prawns was still there. But the middle part is naked, like a grub.
他走到餐馆的一边，爬上一把普通的折叠椅，伸手去够那个挂在天花板下方的长鱼缸。他在水里摆动手指。当他摆动手指时，那些大虾变得愤怒了。它们开始咬他的手指，开始攻击他。他挑出几只最活泼的带回柜台，然后——注意了，没洗手——在虾身上比划了几下。几秒钟后，服务员端着放在一大堆冰块上的虾过来了。他做的是剥掉了外骨骼。虾头是完整的，大虾身上总是有的那小截尾巴也还在。但中间部分是裸露的，像个幼虫。
And I picked up the prawn with my chopsticks, and it was not dead, this prawn. It was extremely alive. And it was wiggling its legs, and it was wiggling its antennas, and its eyes were swiveling madly on its eye stalks. And it was looking back at me, seeing me as actually the predator, the creature that was going to eat it. And that was a really freakish moment, because as much stuff as I eat, and as low as I eat on the food chain, and as many prawns as I have dispatched in my life, I have never before killed a living being with my teeth. And the prawn knew what I was going to do and he did not like it.
我用筷子夹起大虾，这只虾没死。它非常活跃。它在摆动腿，摆动触须，眼睛在眼柄上疯狂转动。它回望着我，看到我实际上是捕食者，那个要吃掉它的生物。那是一个非常诡异的时刻，因为尽管我吃了很多东西，尽管我在食物链中吃的很低，尽管我一生中处理过很多大虾，但我从未用牙齿杀死过一个活物。大虾知道我打算做什么，它不喜欢那样。
And I wasn't quite sure what to do. But if I put it down, the prawn would have died anyway. I mean, it's not going to live without its shell. Somebody else would have eaten it, blah blah blah. So I bit into it. I bit its body off with my teeth. And the prawn just relaxed in this way that was really eerie. And the taste of the prawn, the taste of the meat of it, was extraordinary. It was sweet. It was like there was life coursing through it. It was the most alive thing I've ever eaten, obviously literally.
我不太确定该怎么办。但如果我放下它，大虾无论如何都会死的。我的意思是，没有壳它活不下去。别人也会吃掉它的，等等等等。所以我咬了下去。我用牙齿咬断了它的身体。大虾以一种非常诡异的方式放松了下来。那虾的味道，那种肉的味道，是非凡的。很甜。就像生命在其中流淌。显然，从字面上看，这是我吃过的最有活力的东西。
But again, it was freaky. It was getting too close to the actual nature of consumption, which is killing a living creature with your teeth. And I thought that I'd killed it. But in fact, when I put it down, it still had so much life in it that it grabbed a piece of salmon sashimi and wouldn't let go of it. And I don't think I ever want to do that again.
但同样，这很诡异。这太接近消费的本质了，也就是用牙齿杀死一个活的生物。我以为我已经杀死了它。但事实上，当我把它放下时，它体内依然充满活力，它抓住了一片三文鱼刺身，怎么都不肯松手。我想我再也不想那样做了。
Do you think, in some way, that it's more acceptable to eat an animal if you are more awake to the fact that it is an animal, and what's happened to it? Or do you think it really doesn't matter?
你认为，在某种程度上，如果你对动物是动物的事实以及它所经历的一切有更多的觉知，吃它是否更容易被接受？还是你认为这根本不重要？
I think it matters a great deal. I mean, one of the greatest metaphors in Western civilization is that of, you know, Christ, who gave his life so that others might live. And I don't want to be sacrilegious, and I don't want to belittle that myth in any way, but a pig is giving its life so that we might eat. A chicken is giving its life so that we might eat. And I think the least that we can do is to think about that chicken, to think about that calf that we're eating, not necessarily to be sad for it, but to celebrate it, to be aware of the being that it was, that it wasn't just this bit of bioengineered protein that somehow managed to find its way onto our plates.
我认为这很重要。我的意思是，西方文明中最伟大的隐喻之一就是，你知道，基督，他献出生命让别人得以生存。我不想亵渎，也不想以任何方式贬低那个神话，但猪献出生命让我们得以进食。鸡献出生命让我们得以进食。我认为我们至少能做的就是去思考那只鸡，去思考我们正在吃的牛犊，不一定是为它感到悲伤，而是去赞美它，去意识到它曾经是一个生命，它不仅仅是某种莫名其妙出现在我们盘子里的转基因蛋白质。
Jonathan Gold, food writer for Gourmet magazine. Coming up, a chicken diva just a few inches tall, and how a chicken company changed a white man into a black man. That's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
乔纳森·戈德，《美食》杂志美食作家。接下来，一只几英寸高的小鸡歌后，以及一家养鸡公司如何把一个白人变成了黑人。稍后，节目继续，来自国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, during this period of greatest poultry consumption in our nation, as we do every year at this time on This American Life, we bring you stories of chickens, turkeys, ducks, fowl of all kind, real and imagined. Today we bring you new stories and some favorite from poultry shows past. We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, How to do the Funky Chicken.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选定一个主题，为你带来各种不同类型的主题故事。今天的节目，在这全国禽肉消费最高的时期，正如我们每年此时在《美国生活》所做的那样，我们为你带来真实与想象中的鸡、火鸡、鸭子和各种禽类的故事。今天我们带来新的故事以及过去禽类节目中的一些最爱。我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，《如何跳小鸡舞》。
Well, thus far on our show, we've heard about imaginary poultry in the life of one family. We've heard about poultry as pet and poultry as food. In this act, we examine poultry as a business. It is such a powerful business, says reporter Mark Schone, that it is able to recast human identities. Sometimes.
那么，到目前为止，我们已经听到了关于一个家庭生活中虚构的家禽。我们听到了关于作为宠物的家禽和作为食物的家禽。在这一幕中，我们审视作为企业的家禽业。记者马克·肖恩说，这是一家如此强大的企业，它甚至能够重塑人类的身份。有时。
Anyone older than 30 remembers Colonel Harland Sanders. He was that plantation Santa in the white suit and string tie, the ancient Southern chicken hawker on the TV ads and the talk shows. He'd flash a crinkly country smile at Mike Douglas and act all down home, sharing a few cracker barrel truths about staying happy in old age. Colonel Sanders insisted that fried chicken didn't harden your arteries, and he lived to be 90 years old to prove it. Here's the man himself in a promo film from the '60s.
任何30岁以上的人都记得哈兰德·桑德斯上校。他就是那个穿着白色西装、系着细领带的种植园圣诞老人，那个出现在电视广告和脱口秀节目中的古老南方炸鸡推销员。他会对着迈克·道格拉斯露出那种皱巴巴的乡村笑容，表现得非常乡土，分享一些关于在老年保持快乐的乡村智慧。桑德斯上校坚持认为炸鸡不会导致动脉硬化，而且他活到了90岁来证明这一点。这是他在60年代的一部宣传片中本人出镜。
So I set my yeast, made the sponge, and made the light bread and baked it all, and it was the prettiest loaf of bread that I believe that I most ever seen. So we take my sister and a loaf of bread, and walked this three miles over to [? Andrewville, ?] across the fields and around the highways, carrying this little sister of mine. And we're taking this loaf of bread in to show mom what we had done, don't you see.
所以我准备了酵母，做了面种，烤了白面包，那是我相信自己见过的最漂亮的烤面包。所以我们带着我妹妹和那块面包，走这三英里路去[？]，穿过田野，绕过公路，抱着我这个小妹妹。我们要带着这块面包去给妈妈看我们做了什么，你明白吗。
Now, two decades after he lay in state at the Kentucky capitol building, the Colonel has come back from the dead. He's returned to deliver a message from the other side, but it's hardly the homespun folk wisdom you'd expect.
现在，在他停灵于肯塔基州国会大厦的二十年后，上校死而复生了。他回来传达来自另一侧的消息，但这绝非你所期待的乡土民间智慧。
Hey there! This is your Colonel talking. Now, I've got something here that is downright fun. It's more fun than watchin' me, unless of course Colonel get funky. Go Colonel, go Colonel.
嘿！这是你们的上校在说话。现在，我这儿有些真正好玩的东西。除非上校变得时髦起来，否则这比看我还要好玩。加油上校，加油上校。
Reanimated as a cartoon, the Colonel still has a pink face and white suit, but these days the erstwhile Southern gentleman twirls his cane like Huggy Bear and pimp limps to the greasy beat of old-school '70s funk. When he chants, Go Colonel, he's doing the Cabbage Patch, that annoying end zone celebration of a dance, where the arms stick straight out while the shoulders rotate.
重现为卡通人物后，上校依然有粉红色的脸和白色的西装，但这些天，这位昔日的南方绅士像雨果·贝尔那样转动着他的手杖，随着70年代旧派放克的油腻节拍一瘸一拐地走着。当他高喊“加油上校”时，他在跳“卷心菜娃娃舞”，那种令人讨厌的达阵得分庆祝舞蹈，双臂笔直伸出，肩膀旋转。
Since September 9, 1998, in an ad campaign that began on his 108th birthday, the Colonel has Cabbage Patched, tap danced, rapped, and played basketball. He is not merely risen from the grave, he's risen above the rim, where he catches an alley-oop pass and jams the rock in the hole. The Colonel is now a black man.
自1998年9月9日，在他108岁生日那天开始的广告活动以来，上校已经跳过了卷心菜娃娃舞、踢踏舞、饶舌，还打过篮球。他不仅从坟墓中复活，他甚至飞到了篮筐之上，在那里他接住空中接力传球，将球扣入篮筐。上校现在是个黑人了。
What's it mean when a redneck who dressed like a slave owner comes back from the dead and gets funky? For people who actually knew the Colonel, like biographer John Ed Pearce, his racial makeover can be a little jarring.
一个穿着像奴隶主的乡巴佬死而复生并跳起时髦舞蹈意味着什么？对于那些真正认识上校的人，比如传记作者约翰·埃德·皮尔斯来说，他的种族形象改造可能有点让人不舒服。
I resent it. It depicts the Colonel as a clown, as a song and dance guy. He was a redneck showman and he believed very deeply and thoroughly in publicity. But he was not a clown. He had a certain innate dignity to him.
我对此感到愤怒。这把上校描绘成一个小丑，一个又唱又跳的家伙。他是个乡巴佬表演者，他非常深刻地坚信宣传的力量。但他不是小丑。他身上有一种与生俱来的尊严。
A little chicken music please. [SINGING] The thigh bone's connected to the wing bone. The wing bone's connected to the--
请来点鸡肉音乐。 [唱歌] 大腿骨连着翅骨。翅骨连着——
He was a showman, though. Are you saying he would never sing "Dem Bones?"
但他是个表演者。你是说他永远不会唱《骨头歌》？
No.
不。
Wouldn't do a Cabbage Patch dance?
也不会跳“卷心菜娃娃舞”？
No. That's what I'm trying to say. He was not a clown. Dancing around, twirling his cane, and the Southern accent, which he did not have.
不。这就是我想说的。他不是小丑。跳来跳去，转动手杖，还有南方口音，他其实并没有那种口音。
The real Harland Sanders was an Indiana hick who left home young and had dozens of different careers. At one point, he dressed up as the Michelin man and worked the county fairs. Finally, he settled in southeastern Kentucky and opened a gas station slash motel slash cafe, which became the lab where he perfected his pressure-cooked fried chicken and secret original recipe. For 30 years, he ran the Sanders cafe in Corbin, Kentucky, and earned a rep as a hardass, redneck, potty mouth who really liked the ladies.
真实的哈兰德·桑德斯是个很早就离家出走并从事过几十种职业的印第安纳州乡下人。有一段时间，他打扮成米其林人，在乡村集会上工作。最终，他在肯塔基州东南部定居，开了个加油站兼汽车旅馆兼咖啡馆，那成为了他完善压力锅炸鸡和秘密原始配方的实验室。30年来，他在肯塔基州科尔宾经营桑德斯咖啡馆，并以一个强硬、乡土、满口脏话且很爱女人的形象而闻名。
A woman at the Chamber of Commerce told me that every time Harland came in, why, she had to beat his hands off of her. And she told him, Harland, get your hands off me. I got all I need at home.
商会的一位女士告诉我，每次哈兰德进来，她都不得不把他的手从她身上拍掉。她告诉他，哈兰德，把你的手从我身上拿开。我在家里已经够满足了。
When he wasn't cussing and adulterin', he was not loving his neighbor as himself. The Colonel welcomed a fight and fought to win by any means necessary. There are countless tales of him throwing knives, plates, and chunks of concrete, and lashing out with canes and chairs up past the age of 70. This supposed Southern gentleman guarded his turf like a South Central Crip.
当他不骂人和偷情的时候，他并没有爱邻如己。上校欢迎打架，并誓要不择手段地获胜。有无数关于他投掷刀、盘子和混凝土块，并在70多岁时挥舞拐杖和椅子打人的故事。这位所谓的南方绅士守护自己的地盘就像个南中央区的帮派成员。
In 1931, he and his homies confronted a rival who was painting over his billboards. The punk was tagging the Colonel's signs. Sanders let the bullets rip. The original recipe gangsta drilled his foe in the breast and thigh.
1931年，他和他的同伙与一个在涂改他广告牌的对手对峙。那个小混混在涂鸦上校的广告牌。桑德斯开了枪。这位原始配方黑帮分子打中了对手的胸部和大腿。
At KFC, we do chicken right! And not just in a bucket neither. The Colonel? He the man.
在肯德基，我们的鸡肉做得最好！不仅仅是在桶里。上校？他就是那个人。
The most delicious thought about the commercials that turned Colonel Sanders into a black man is the oh-wouldn't-it-be-so-ironic possibility that this elderly Southerner was a racist. He did once ride in a parade with segregationist hero George Wallace. His adopted hometown of Corbin was a don't-let-the-sun-set-on-you kind of place, known and feared among Kentucky blacks, particularly after an episode of ethnic cleansing in 1919, when a posse of whites lynched a few local blacks, burned others, and put the survivors on a train out of town.
关于把桑德斯上校变成黑人的广告，最令人玩味的讽刺是：这位老南方人可能是一个种族主义者。他确实曾经和种族隔离英雄乔治·华莱士一起参加过游行。他收养的家乡科尔宾是一个“太阳下山就别留下来”的地方，在肯塔基州的黑人中众所周知且令人恐惧，特别是在1919年发生了一起种族清洗事件后，当时一群白人私刑处死了几名当地黑人，烧毁了其他人的房屋，并把幸存者赶上了离城的火车。
And it probably didn't help that halfway through the century, at age 60, Harland Sanders decided to become Colonel Sanders. Mimicking a Southern planter, he began sporting a white suit, string tie, and walking stick. A hairdresser died his goatee white to match his hair. In 1974, the freaky blacksploitation flick, Darktown Strutters , channeled the worst suspicions of blacks and liberals. The villain of the film is a Colonel Sanders clone whose fast food empire hides an underground Ku Klux Klavern full of racist bikers.
而且，这大概也无济于事：在本世纪中叶，60岁时，哈兰德·桑德斯决定成为桑德斯上校。他模仿南方种植园主，开始穿白色西装、系细领带、拿手杖。理发师把他的山羊胡染成白色，与头发相配。1974年，那部怪异的黑人剥削电影《黑城叛徒》表达了黑人和自由派最坏的怀疑。电影里的反派是一个桑德斯上校的克隆人，他的快餐帝国隐藏着一个充满种族主义摩托党徒的地下三K党分支。
There wasn't a racist bone in his body. For that fact, he bent over backwards to make a change. If the perception of him being a racist was real, he wanted to overcome that.
他身上没有任何种族主义的骨头。事实上，他竭尽全力去做出改变。如果关于他是种族主义者的看法是真实的，他想要克服这一点。
As head of public relations for Kentucky Fried Chicken in the late '70s, Ray Callender traveled the country with the Colonel for several years. He had to kick his boss under the table sometimes to stop him griping to the press about the declining quality of Kentucky Fried Chicken, and he heard a lot of salty language in the back of the Colonel's white Caddy. But as a black man riding shotgun for the very emblem of white southernness, Callender never once caught Sanders saying the n-word.
作为70年代末肯塔基炸鸡公司的公关主管，雷·卡伦德曾随上校在全国各地旅行了好几年。他有时不得不踢上校的腿，阻止他向媒体抱怨肯德基鸡肉质量的下降，他在上校的白色凯迪拉克后座听到了很多粗俗的语言。但作为一个给这位白人南方象征开车的黑人，卡伦德一次也没听到桑德斯说过那个N开头的词。
And the only close incident that came like that was when he was writing his own little speech in preparation for whatever was going on, and he turned to me and said, he wanted to know what us nice folks were calling ourselves these days. And I looked up and I said, well, what do you mean? And he said, well, is-- his term was-- he didn't say nigger. It was Negra. And I said, oh, this is where it comes to a stop. Nowadays we call ourselves black. And then he would say, Well, I wouldn't call you nice folks black. To the Colonel, black was a derogatory term to him. And you can imagine coming through that time, that's-- he was raised in that environment.
唯一类似的情况是，当他在准备演讲稿时，他转过来问我，他想知道我们这些好人现在怎么称呼自己。我抬头说，好吧，你指什么？他说，嗯，是——他的词——他没说那个贬义词，而是“尼格罗”（Negra）。我说，哦，这就不对了。现在我们叫自己黑人。然后他说，好吧，我不会叫你们这些好人为黑人。对上校来说，黑人这个词对他来说是贬义的。你可以想象，在那个时代成长起来的人，他就是在那种环境中长大的。
Of course, when we travelled out, we'd rent limousines. And in the case with me traveling with the Colonel, I always sat in the back, believe it or not, and he sat up front with the driver. And what he would do, when we got to the motel where we stayed, he jumped out of the car and ran to the back to open the door for me, and run ahead to the hotel and guide me through the door, and he would carry the bags. And we had, at that point, back in 1976, the doorman came to me, scratching his head, and said, you know, I know that man is Colonel Sanders, that Kentucky Fried Chicken guy, millionaire. And I said, yeah. And he said, well, who the hell are you? And the Colonel said, that's my son, but we don't talk about that.
当然，当我们外出旅行时，我们会租豪华轿车。我和上校一起旅行时，信不信由你，我总是坐在后座，他坐在前排和司机在一起。每次到达我们下榻的汽车旅馆，他都会跳下车跑去后面帮我开车门，并跑到酒店前面引导我进门，还要帮我提行李。1976年，门卫抓着头问我，你知道，我知道那人是桑德斯上校，肯塔基炸鸡那个亿万富翁。我说，是的。他说，那么你到底是谁？上校说，那是我的儿子，但我们不谈这个。
After the Colonel died, his empire got in a mess of trouble, running around like a chicken chain with its head cut off. There was the unhealthy vibe of that bad word, fried, easily fixed by changing the name to KFC. But more importantly, there was the morphing of fast food from carry-out to eat-in. Buckets of chicken were old-timey, like families eating dinner together at home. KFC needed new products, like sandwiches, that people could eat in the store for lunch. And there was the matter of the dead company spokesman. Last year, after many false starts, KFC solved the product and pitching problems in one fell swoop. It debuted a line of sandwiches and other boneless items, and it brought the Colonel back as a cartoon to sell them. The impact, says Peter Folds, KFC's chief image and ad director, was immediate.
上校去世后，他的帝国陷入了一团混乱，就像一只断了头的鸡在乱撞。有“炸”这个词带来的不健康氛围，通过更名为KFC很容易解决。但更重要的是，快餐形式从外带变成了堂食。桶装鸡肉显得老派，就像一家人在一起吃晚饭。KFC需要新产品，比如三明治，人们可以在店里吃午餐。还有已故公司代言人的问题。去年，在经历了多次失败尝试后，KFC一举解决了产品和推销问题。它推出了系列三明治和其他无骨产品，并让上校作为卡通形象回归来销售它们。KFC首席形象和广告总监彼得·福尔兹说，效果是立竿见影的。
And that's when we knew we had a hit on our hands, because literally outside of the office you'd have people doing that Cabbage Patch dance and going, go Colonel, go Colonel. So we knew we had something good on our hands then. Out in the street. I mean, people in a store. You'd go in a grocery store, and I'd be in an aisle, and I'd see a little kid doing that, showing her mother that she could do that. So just very spontaneous.
那就是我们知道我们大获成功的时候，因为在办公室外，真的有人在跳那种“卷心菜娃娃舞”并大喊，加油上校，加油上校。所以我们当时就知道我们手头上有好东西。在街上。我的意思是，商店里的人。你会去杂货店，我在过道里，会看到一个小孩子在做那个动作，向她妈妈展示她会做那个。所以是非常自发的。
I am getting a tan.
我在晒黑。
Folds denies the new animated Colonel is in any way urban, to use ad-speak for black. He confirms, however, that the KFC brand name is more popular among blacks than whites, and he claims the Cabbage Patch Colonel has been embraced by black consumers. According to Folds, the campaign has clicked so well with everybody in America that sales have risen 6% and KFC's once sleepy lunch hour is jumping. Again, Ray Callender.
福尔兹否认新的动画上校在任何方面是“城市化”的，也就是广告行话里“黑人”的委婉语。然而，他证实KFC品牌在黑人中比在白人中更受欢迎，并声称“卷心菜娃娃舞”上校已经受到了黑人消费者的欢迎。据福尔兹说，这一运动在全美每个人中都产生了如此好的反响，以至于销售额增长了6%，KFC曾经沉闷的午餐时段变得活跃起来。再次采访雷·卡伦德。
I think the ad campaign is great in more ways than one, because since I did travel with the Colonel, it kind of reminded me of him, kind of nostalgic kind of trip.
我认为这个广告活动在很多方面都很棒，因为自从我随上校旅行以来，它让我回忆起了他，有一种怀旧的旅程。
And you think he would be OK with what they've done with his image?
你认为他会对他们用他的形象所做的事感到满意吗？
I know that, because I know what he was trying to accomplish when he was alive. I mean, at that time, I was travelling with him, he wanted to be more involved in the minority community. In light of, I think at that time, sales-- more than 40% of our sales-- were from the minority community. And he actually wanted to go learn Spanish and do commercials in Spanish, and visit with the minority community in New York City, in Harlem in particular.
我知道他会，因为我知道他生前想要完成什么。我的意思是，那段时期，我和他旅行时，他想要更多地参与到少数族裔社区中。考虑到，我想当时销售额——超过40%的销售额——来自少数族裔社区。他甚至真的想学西班牙语，用西班牙语做广告，并访问纽约市的少数族裔社区，特别是哈莱姆区。
So it sounds like he was, you know, if it would sell some chicken, he would do it.
所以听起来，如果那样能卖掉一些鸡肉，他就会去做。
If it sold chicken, he would do it.
如果能卖掉鸡肉，他就会去做。
[SOUND OF PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Keisha, are you ready for this? We can get two pieces of chicken, leg or thigh, a side and a biscuit for just $1.99!
基莎，你准备好了吗？我们可以用1.99美元买到两块鸡肉，腿部或大腿，一份配菜和一块饼干！
Where?
在哪里？
At KFC, girl! [CALL WAITING BEEP] One second, Keisha. Hello?
在肯德基，女孩！[呼叫等待声] 等一下，基莎。喂？
Hey, it's the Colonel.
嘿，我是上校。
The Colonel?
上校？
I just want to tell you my original recipe chicken is finger-licking kicking! And my square meal deal is for real!
我只是想告诉你，我的原始配方鸡肉让人舔手指！我的套餐是来真的！
The Colonel is free at last. Thank God Almighty, he's free at last. And the black man set him free. An urbanized tune has taken the last lingering stink of the old South off him. Once upon a time, in true American style, he invented himself. And now we are reinventing him. I confess I have a crush on the new, improved, funky Colonel. His patchwork soul is exactly what makes me get all maudlin about America. I'm proud to live in a country where any little white boy, from any small redneck town, through hard work and perseverance, can someday, if he's lucky, grow up to be a black man.
上校终于自由了。感谢全能的上帝，他终于自由了。黑人让他自由了。一种城市化的曲调洗去了他身上残存的旧南方臭气。曾经，以真正的美国方式，他发明了自己。而现在，我们正在重塑他。我承认我迷上了这个新的、改进的、时髦的上校。他那缝补起来的灵魂正是让我对美国感到伤感的原因。我为生活在这个国家而自豪，在这个国家，任何一个小男孩，来自任何一个小乡镇，通过努力工作和坚持不懈，如果他幸运的话，有朝一日都能长大成为一个黑人。
Mark Schone is a writer living in Brooklyn.
马克·肖恩是一位居住在布鲁克林的作家。
[MUSIC -- FROM AN OLD DOCUMENTARY ABOUT COLONEL SANDERS]
[音乐——来自一部关于桑德斯上校的旧纪录片]
Act Four, Chicken Diva. In the end it seems, when humans are concerned, chickens are what we make of them. For further evidence, we have this story from Jack Hitt.
第四幕，《小鸡歌后》。到头来，当涉及到人类时，鸡成为了我们赋予它们定义的样子。为了进一步证明，我们请来了杰克·希特的故事。
Oddly enough, it wasn't Susan who was obsessed with chickens. It was Kenny, a pal who worked backstage at the 92nd Street Y in New York. His house was filled with chicken cups, chicken masks. He got the whole staff onto chickens, including Susan. For a time there in the '80s, poultry-related jokes and references became the fast way to get a laugh at the Y.
奇怪的是，痴迷于鸡的并不是苏珊。而是肯尼，一个在纽约第92街Y中心后台工作的朋友。他的房子里到处是鸡杯、鸡面具。他让整个员工团队都迷上了鸡，包括苏珊。在80年代的那段时间里，禽类相关的笑话和引用成了在Y中心博取欢笑的捷径。
I guess most of us are condemned to see nothing more than the easy comedy of chickens. But Susan Vitucci saw something else, their potential greatness, their hidden beauty, their grandeur. One day she glued together some finger puppets for a 10-minute rendition of the Chicken Little story for her nephew. That was 14 years ago. Today it is a full-length opera, enjoyed by a cult following whenever it goes up in a workshop or cafe or small theater. It's still performed with finger puppets, but now it has a complete score written by a noted composer, Henry Krieger, who did Dreamgirls. The Chicken Little opera he wrote with Susan Vitucci is called Love's Fowl. Needless to say, that's F-O-W-L.
我想我们大多数人注定只能看到鸡带来的轻松喜剧。但苏珊·维图奇看到了别的东西，它们的潜在伟大、隐藏的美丽、宏伟。有一天，她为了侄子把一些手指木偶粘在一起，排演了10分钟的《四眼天鸡》故事。那是14年前的事了。今天，它已经成为一部全长歌剧，无论是在工作坊、咖啡馆还是小剧院上演，都会受到狂热粉丝的喜爱。它依然由手指木偶表演，但现在有了由著名作曲家亨利·克里格——《追梦女孩》的编曲——创作的完整乐谱。他与苏珊·维图奇创作的《四眼天鸡》歌剧名为《爱的禽类》（Love's Fowl）。不用说，拼写是F-O-W-L。
Well, we were going to start with the opening, the opening [SPEAKING ITALIAN]. We are the Clothespin Repertory Theater. And we have a special singing guest for you, which, I don't know--
嗯，我们打算从开场开始，开场[用意大利语说]。我们是晾衣夹剧团。我们有一个特别的演唱嘉宾，这让我想起——
Susan and I are sitting at Henry's baby grand piano. Henry's guest is his Maltese terrier named Toby.
苏珊和我坐在亨利的三角钢琴前。亨利的客人是一只名叫托比的马耳他犬。
Perhaps Toby would be kind enough--
也许托比会很乐意——
Yeah, would she sit on your lap for this?
是啊，你能让它坐在你的腿上表演吗？
Yeah, let's see what we can do. OK
好的，让我们看看能做什么。好了。
OK, listen carefully, because once Toby gets going, he actually harmonizes with Henry and Susan.
好的，仔细听，因为一旦托比开始，它其实会和亨利与苏珊和声。
[HENRY KRIEGER AND SUSAN VITUCCI SINGING IN ITALIAN WITH DOG]
[亨利·克里格和苏珊·维图奇用意大利语与狗一起演唱]
You may have noticed that this libretto is in Italian, just like a real opera.
你可能注意到了，这个剧本用意大利语写成，就像真正的歌剧一样。
Before, it was just a bunch of puppets in a box, you know, with a good idea. And then, suddenly, as soon as it went into Italian, it became something bigger than what it had been. And it's because, when it's in English, we all kind of know it and it's really not that interesting. And it's like, yeah, yeah, yeah. As soon as it's in Italian, it gives us enough distance that we can come in. It's like the lover who doesn't want you. You don't want anybody more than you want the one who doesn't want you. Right? And so it's sort of the same thing.
以前，它只是盒子里的一堆木偶，你知道，带着一个好主意。然后，突然，一旦用上了意大利语，它就变得比以前更宏大了。这是因为，当用英语时，我们大家都太熟悉了，实际上并不那么有趣。就像，是啊是啊是啊。一旦用意大利语，它就给了我们足够的距离感，让我们能进入其中。就像那个不要你的爱人。你最渴望的莫过于那个不要你的人。对吧？所以这是一样的道理。
[SUSAN VITUCCI SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[苏珊·维图奇用意大利语演唱]
You may recall that when you last heard of Little, back in kindergarten, she was just an average barn door fowl, who had an acorn drop on her head, which she mistakenly understood to be the sky falling. Her alarms excited her friends, Goosey Loosey, Turkey Lurkey, and Ducky Lucky, and they join her for a journey to the king to tell him the important news. On the way, they meet up with Sly Fox. Little's pals eagerly accept his invitation for dinner, literally, as it turns out. Fortunately for Little, hunger is not enough to distract her from her mission, and she treks on. When she meets the king, he tells her that the sky's not falling, it's just an acorn. So the enlightened Chicken Little returns to her coop, and that's where the story ends.
你可能还记得，上次听说“天鸡”是在幼儿园的时候，她只是一只普通的农场家禽，一个橡子掉在她头上，她误以为是天要塌了。她的警报让她的朋友们——鹅鹅、火鸡鲁鲁和鸭子吉吉都很兴奋，他们陪她一起去找国王告诉他这个重要的消息。路上，他们遇到了狡猾的狐狸。天鸡的朋友们急切地接受了他的晚餐邀请，结果正如事实证明，他们成了晚餐。幸运的是，饥饿并没有让她偏离使命，她继续前行。当她见到国王时，他告诉她天没有塌，那只是一个橡子。于是，开悟的天鸡回到了她的鸡舍，故事就在那里结束了。
What are we to take away from Little's experience? I like to think it's that Little is rewarded with life, precisely because she went off on this quixotic mission, totally in the grip of a wrong idea.
我们能从天鸡的经历中学到什么？我喜欢认为这是因为她踏上了这次堂吉诃德式的使命，完全沉浸在一个错误的观念中，才最终获得了生命。
[SUSAN VITUCCI SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[苏珊·维图奇用意大利语演唱]
The children's fable barely figures into the story. It's just one small episode in the life of Chicken Little, now known as La Pulcina Piccola. After the acorn incident, she goes on to become an internationally renowned figure in almost every field imaginable, a diva of politics, academe, theater, art, derring-do. Like Venus, she arrives from some other world, transported on a scallop shell, but the triumphs of her life begin after a youthful love affair with a fighting cock ends bitterly, and she consoles herself-- as we all do at some point in our lives-- by plunging into Shakespeare. She becomes an overnight sensation as an actress, celebrated all over the world for one role. Juliet? Cleopatra? Ophelia?
儿童寓言几乎没出现在这个故事里。这只是天鸡一生中的一个小插曲，她现在被称为“La Pulcina Piccola”。橡子事件后，她继续成为几乎所有领域都知名的国际性人物，无论是政治、学术、戏剧、艺术、冒险，她都是歌后。像维纳斯一样，她从另一个世界降临，乘坐扇贝壳运输，但她生命的胜利始于一段与斗鸡的青春恋情苦涩地结束后，她安慰自己——正如我们一生中某个时刻所做的那样——沉浸在莎士比亚的作品中。她在一夜之间成为一名女演员，因一个角色而享誉世界。朱丽叶？克利奥帕特拉？奥菲利亚？
The company then performs an excerpt, a recreation of her signature role, which is Richard III. Well, you know, I mean, Sarah Bernhardt did Hamlet--
剧团随后表演了一个节选，重现了她的招牌角色，也就是《理查三世》。嗯，你知道，我的意思是，莎拉·伯恩哈特演过哈姆雷特——
Well, there's a great tradition of women playing the men's roles in Shakespeare, but I think Richard III is one of the more rare roles to be played by a woman.
嗯，女性扮演莎士比亚男性角色有很棒的传统，但我认为《理查三世》是女性扮演的最罕见的角色之一。
Well, that's how adventuresome an actress this chicken was.
好吧，这就是这只鸡作为女演员有多爱冒险。
I can assure you, there's nothing like watching a four-inch tall finger puppet crying out, a horse! A horse! My kingdom for a horse! in Italian. Not to mention that that puppet is a chicken, surrounded by a whole supporting cast of poultry, and other avian supernumeraries. Susan says that, artistically, there's something special about chickens.
我可以保证，没什么比看一个四英寸高的手指木偶用意大利语喊着“一匹马！一匹马！我的王国换一匹马！”更奇妙的了。更不用说那个木偶是一只鸡，周围有一整群家禽支持演员和其他鸟类配角。苏珊说，从艺术上讲，鸡身上确实有些特别之处。
They're a clean slate. You can put anything on them. You can project anything onto them, because it's not like they have, to me at least, a very strong personality.
它们是一张白纸。你可以把任何东西放在它们身上。你可以把任何东西投射到它们身上，因为在我看来，它们不像是有非常强烈的个性。
Except for La Pulcina. In the opera, she moves into the field of archaeology, masters it, needless to say, and makes a great discovery, the last tomb of Gallapatra, but not before she sails the Seven Seas, is shipwrecked, gets rescued, but it's by pirates, and then she meets the pirate king.
除了“La Pulcina”。在歌剧中，她进入了考古领域，不用说，她精通了考古，并有了伟大发现，加拉帕特拉的最后墓穴，但在此之前，她航行在七大洋，遭遇海难，获救，是被海盗救的，然后她遇到了海盗王。
As soon as he meets her, he falls in love with her, because of her sweet spirit. Because she comes in and she says, here you see a little chicken, who, although I'm dripping wet, I'm proud and yellow.
他一见到她就爱上了她，因为她甜美的灵魂。因为她走进来，她说，在这里你看到一只小鸡，虽然我湿透了，但我自豪且金黄。
Let me repeat that lyric for you, in a purer translation. Although I stand before you, a chicken, who is dripping wet, I am proud and I am yellow. OK, back to Susan.
让我为你重复那段歌词，用更纯粹的翻译。虽然我站在你面前，是一只全身湿透的小鸡，但我自豪，而且我是金黄的。好了，回到苏珊。
And although I have loved and I have lost, I have learned to follow the call of adventure. So let's sail on.
虽然我爱过也失去过，但我学会了追随冒险的呼唤。所以让我们起航吧。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
Keep in mind that all of the action, like everything that occurs in every Susan Vitucci production, ever since the first one for her nephew, and continuing to this day, occurs among characters created by sticking a small painted Styrofoam ball onto a larger painted Styrofoam ball, poking in two map tacks for eyes, gluing on a tiny felt beak, and then impaling the whole thing on top of one of those really old-fashioned clothes pins that a '40s cartoon figure would clamp to his nose around a chunk of Limburger cheese.
记住所有的动作，就像苏珊·维图奇作品中发生的每一件事一样，自从为她侄子做的第一部作品以来，一直持续到今天，都发生在通过把一个小彩绘泡沫球粘在一个较大的彩绘泡沫球上，戳两个图钉当眼睛，粘上一个微小的毛毡喙，然后把整个东西插在那根真的很老式的晾衣夹上——那种40年代的卡通人物会夹在鼻子上来吃林堡干酪的晾衣夹——所创造的角色之中。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
And I could go on. Susan has written, or as she puts it, translated La Pulcina Piccola's diaries, which detail the other adventures that happened in between those in the opera. There are 60 pages so far, excerpts of which have appeared in Clotheslines, the official fan club newsletter of the opera. Love's Fowl has a strange effect on people. I didn't understand it until Susan loaned me a videotape of one performance. To be honest, I thought I would be annoyed at the intentional irony and hokeyness of the puppets. But there I was, with my three-year-old daughter, who loved the show, watching a plastic bird pantomime one of the simplest human moments, but also one of the most profound, the confession of a great love. In this case, with a cock robin.
我还可以继续。苏珊写了，或者正如她所说的，翻译了“La Pulcina Piccola”的日记，详细记录了歌剧之外发生的其他冒险。目前已经有60页了，摘录曾出现在歌剧的官方粉丝俱乐部通讯《晾衣绳》中。《爱的禽类》对人们有一种奇怪的影响。我直到苏珊借给我一个演出的录像带才明白。老实说，我原以为我会因为木偶的刻意讽刺和蹩脚而感到恼火。但就在那里，我和我三岁的女儿，她很爱这部戏，看着一只塑料鸟模仿人类最简单的时刻，但也是最深刻的时刻之一，那就是承认一份伟大的爱。在这种情况下，对象是一只知更鸟。
The song that she sings as she enters goes, I am a chicken and ready for love. My heart is as fragile as the egg from which I was born. Treat me gently and so will I treat you. Together from earthly love we will reach for the divine. And then she sings, I am a chicken and I can't fly without love. My heart it is strong as the egg from which I was born. And so forth. And so, it is only with cock robin that she flies.
她登场时唱的歌是：“我是一只准备好去爱的小鸡。我的心像我出生的蛋一样脆弱。温柔地对待我，我也会同样对待你。我们将一起从世俗之爱迈向神圣。”然后她唱：“我是一只没有爱就无法飞行的小鸡。我的心像我出生的蛋一样坚强。”以此类推。所以，她只与知更鸟一起飞行。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
And after they've agreed to fly together, and they're soaring in the air, cock robin is shot and killed, murdered by a jealous sparrow. I couldn't believe it, but I was getting choked up, especially when cock robin appeared on the stage, his Styrofoam body spray painted black for the lament, his little magic marker eyes drawn as X's. I gathered my daughter in my arms and held on tight as I was helplessly drawn into an expression of the grief and suffering of this little sad bird. In this era of slick special effects, there was something unexpectedly liberating in the marriage of this crude medium, painted Styrofoam balls bobbing up and down behind a cardboard box, and the high melodramatic art of Italian opera. Picture it.
在他们同意一起飞翔并且翱翔在空中后，知更鸟被射杀身亡，被一只嫉妒的麻雀谋杀了。我不敢相信，但我哽咽了，特别是当知更鸟出现在舞台上时，他的泡沫身体被喷涂成黑色，眼睛被画成叉号。我把女儿揽入怀中，紧紧抱住，因为我无可奈何地被吸入了这只悲伤的小鸟的哀伤和痛苦的表达中。在这个华丽特效的时代，将这种原始媒介——在硬纸板盒后上下跳动的彩绘泡沫球——与意大利歌剧的高雅悲剧艺术结合在一起，有着某种出人意料的解放感。想象一下。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
I want a subscription to that newsletter.
我想要那个通讯的订阅。
Are you going to do this? I mean, are you going to be working with Pulcina Piccola you think for the rest of your life?
你打算这样做吗？我的意思是，你认为你会和“Pulcina Piccola”一起工作余生吗？
It's possible. And I like working with her because I get to go into a world that's inhabited by a very sweet spirit and play with the mechanics of the world. And because it's very small-- like, I could never have afforded to produce this show with people. But I could afford to do it with clothespins. So I can do as big a production as I want with clothespins. I can have stuff fly in and out and come in from traps, and I can have all kinds of fancy, flashy stuff that costs millions of dollars to do on Broadway. And it cost me $200 because I had to buy lots and lots of Styrofoam and clothespins and stuff, and all this, and a new table maybe, and I get to do whatever I want.
有可能。我喜欢和她一起工作，因为我可以进入一个有着非常甜美灵魂的世界，并摆弄这个世界的机制。而且因为这非常小——比如，我永远无法负担用真人制作这部戏。但我负担得起用晾衣夹来做。所以我可以随心所欲地制作像我想做的那么大的作品。我可以让东西飞进飞出，从陷阱里出来，我可以有各种百老汇花几百万美元才能做的花哨的东西。而这只花了我200美元，因为我得买很多很多的泡沫球和晾衣夹之类的东西，还有这一切，也许还有一张新桌子，我可以做任何我想做的事。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
Jack Hitt's a writer who lives in New Haven.
杰克·希特是一位居住在纽黑文的作家。
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, Alix Spiegel, Julie Snyder, and Nancy Updike. Musical help from John Connors. Thanks also to Larry Josephson and Jay Hedblade. Elizabeth Meister runs our website.
我们的节目今天由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我自己制作，苏珊·伯顿、蓝色·切维尼、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、朱莉·斯奈德和南希·厄普代克参与。音乐协助由约翰·康纳斯提供。也要感谢拉里·约瑟夫森和杰·赫德布莱德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。
Susan Vitucci's opera about Chicken Little is available on CD at www.pulcina.org. That's pulcina spelled, of course, P-U-L-C-I-N-A.org. To buy a cassette of this or any of our non-poultry oriented shows, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or visit our website, where you can also listen to our programs for free, www.thisamericanlife.org.
苏珊·维图奇关于《四眼天鸡》的歌剧CD可在www.pulcina.org购买。Pulcina拼写，当然是P-U-L-C-I-N-A.org。要购买本节目或我们任何非禽类节目的磁带，请致电芝加哥的WBEZ，电话312-832-3380。或访问我们的网站，您也可以在那里免费收听我们的节目，www.thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助商致谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who decided he did not want to come onto our program after he asked just one question.
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚，他决定在问了一个问题后，不想上我们的节目。
This is just radio? Not TV?
这只是广播节目吗？不是电视？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台（PRI）。